Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Remember, remember the 5th of November.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。记住，记住，11月5日。
Gunpowder, treason and plot. I see no reason why gunpowder treason should ever be forgot. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We are, of course, talking about the gunpowder plot and Bonfire Night, which is tomorrow, Tom Holland. Are you a Bonfire Night aficionado? Well, I'm not because I'm very worried about hedgehogs. about the gunpowder plot and bonfire night which is tomorrow tom holland are you looking for are you are you a bonfire night aficionado uh well i'm not because i'm very worried about hedgehogs oh yes yeah i read this hedgehogs hibernate uh so they're you know this is exactly the time of
火药、叛国与阴谋。我看不出有什么理由让火药叛国永远被遗忘。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。我们今天当然要聊聊火药阴谋和篝火之夜，也就是明天，托马斯·霍兰德。你是个篝火之夜迷吗？嗯，我不是，因为我很担心刺猬。关于火药阴谋和篝火之夜，也就是明天，托马斯·霍兰德，你在寻找，你是，你是篝火之夜迷吗？呃，嗯，我不是，因为我很担心刺猬。哦，是的，对，我读到过刺猬要冬眠，所以它们，你知道的，这正是……
the year they're looking for a large collection of you know brushwood or something to settle down in so they they find you know these large bonfires and they think oh excellent here's a place to stay for the winter. And then the next thing they know, they're being burnt to death. So I'm very worried about that. Well, I think surely the answer to this is look out for hedgehogs,
一年中的这个时候，它们在寻找大量，你知道的，灌木丛或类似的东西来安顿下来。所以它们会找到，你知道的，这些大篝火，然后它们会想，哦太好了，这是个过冬的好地方。接着它们所知道的下一件事，就是它们被活活烧死了。所以我非常担心这一点。嗯，我想解决这个问题的方法肯定是注意刺猬，
but you should have a bonfire because it's very important to remember this shocking moment in 1605 when Guy Fawkes and co. tried to blow up the House of Parliament. Do you not think? Well, so that was the question, wasn't it? In the doggerel that you just quoted,
但你还是应该办个篝火晚会，因为记住1605年盖伊·福克斯等人试图炸毁议会大厦这个令人震惊的时刻非常重要。你不觉得吗？嗯，所以这就是问题所在，对吧？在你刚才引用的顺口溜里，
the famous doggerel. Yeah, no reason. Should it be remembered? Of course it should. I mean, it's interesting. I guess it should be remembered because it is an amazing story. It's absolutely kind of prototypical terrorist attack.
那个著名的顺口溜。对，没理由。应该被记住吗？当然应该。我的意思是，这很有趣。我想它应该被记住，因为它是一个了不起的故事。这绝对是一种原型式的恐怖袭击。
Great drama. Yeah. But it's also fascinating for the various ways in which it's been remembered. So the gunpowder plot. Now, I am conscious that we have lots of overseas listeners who unaccountably won't know what the gunpowder plot is. What? They don't celebrate it overseas?
精彩的戏剧。是的。但它也引人入胜，因为人们对它的纪念方式多种多样。所以火药阴谋。现在，我意识到我们有很多海外听众，他们莫名其妙地不知道什么是火药阴谋。什么？他们在海外不庆祝这个吗？
Shockingly, in Catholic countries, they don't tend to celebrate it. So basically, 1605, this is a plot by Catholic conspirators with a man called Guy Fawkes, much to the fore to blow up the houses of parliament Guy Fawkes is discovered and the plot is foiled and Tom we have celebrated its defeat ever since have we not yes and overseas listeners may have seen the film V for Vendetta which is themed around Guy Fawkes night and there's a kind of mask with a figure with a beard, moustache, which has become very kind of popular with, I mean, all kinds of kind of protest movements. So you may have seen it with that. Anyway, it has been, I suppose, to a degree, is still a big deal in England. And I would guess you could say that today, in a country that's becoming ever less overtly Protestant, and the whole
令人震惊的是，在天主教国家，他们往往不庆祝这个。所以基本上，在1605年，这是一场由天主教阴谋分子策划的阴谋，一个名叫盖伊·福克斯的人冲在最前面，企图炸毁议会大厦。盖伊·福克斯被发现了，阴谋被粉碎了，托马斯，我们从那以后一直在庆祝它的失败，不是吗？是的，海外听众可能看过电影《V字仇杀队》，它是以盖伊·福克斯之夜为主题的，里面有一个戴着面具的人物，有胡子、髭，这种形象已经变得非常受欢迎，我是说，在各种抗议运动中都是如此。所以你可能通过那个见过它。无论如何，它曾经是，我想在某种程度上，在英国仍然是一件大事。而且我想你可以说，在今天这样一个日益不再那么公开信奉新教的国家，整个……
narrative is about Protestants and Catholics, that it is actually starting to be forgot. Do you know, Tom, it saddens me, but I think you're right. As a stout-hearted Englishman. I'm a complete traditionalist, Rick and Mr. Bonfire Knight. You know, when I read about people in Lewes burning, they burn Pope Paul V or something, do they, in Sussex? Well, no, in Lewes, they do. they always burn him but and they burn guy fawkes and donald trump but also yes they they burn people who are in the news i i utterly approve of that i i i want to see
叙事都是关于新教徒和天主教徒的，事实上它已经开始被遗忘。你知道吗，托马斯，这让我感到难过，但我认为你是对的。作为一个坚定不移的英国人。我是一个彻头彻尾的传统主义者，里克，也是篝火之夜先生。你知道，当我读到苏塞克斯郡刘易斯的民众烧毁教皇保罗五世或其他什么人的时候，他们是在那里烧吗？哦，不，在刘易斯，他们确实这么做。他们总是烧他，而且他们还烧盖伊·福克斯和唐纳德·特朗普，还有是的，他们烧那些上新闻的人。我我完全赞成这一点。我我希望看到
apprentices constructing effigies of national enemies you know do you think that they should they should put cats inside the uh i probably draw the line the cats so they then howl as they as the effigy burns which they used to do did they used i didn't know they used to put cats you're not that much of a traditionalist there's amazing stuff actually we'll come to in the second half of this about uh rioting 19th century and stuff. And also Bonfire Night celebrations in America, which is... That's a weird thing, isn't it? I mean, that really... Well, it's only weird, only seems weird now,
学徒们制作国家敌人的肖像，你知道的，你认为他们应该把猫放进……呃，我可能对猫划清界限。这样当肖像燃烧时，它们就会尖叫，他们以前经常这么做。他们以前这样做过吗？我不知道他们以前把猫放进去。你没那么传统。其实这里面有一些了不起的内容，我们会在本集的后半部分讲到19世纪的暴动等等。还有在美国的篝火之夜庆祝活动，那是……那是件奇怪的事，不是吗？我的意思是，那真的……嗯，这只是奇怪，现在看起来才奇怪，
but of course it wouldn't have seemed weird in the 18th century. We'll come to all that, because it's always thought that Bonfire Night is a peculiarly British, if not English, thing. But of course, for a long time, it wasn't. So it did spread to the colonists and so on. But we'll get onto that that because we should probably kick off with the plot itself because it is an absolutely fantastic story, isn't it? Well, yes, except that it's complicated, isn't it?
但当然在18世纪它看起来就不会奇怪了。我们待会儿会讲到所有这些，因为人们总是认为篝火之夜是英国特有的，如果不是英格兰特有的东西的话。但当然，在很长一段时间里，并非如此。所以它确实传播到了殖民地等等。但我们会谈到这一点，因为我们可能应该从阴谋本身开始讲起，因为它确实是一个绝对精彩的故事，不是吗？嗯，是的，不过它很复杂，不是吗？
It is complicated, as all good terrorist plots are. Well, it's very Le Carre. It's very Le Carre. And it's very Le Carre-esque, I guess, for two reasons. Firstly, that it's never entirely clear who the goodies and the baddies are. That's right. Yeah. Obviously, for most of 17th and 18th and into the 19th century in England, it was clear who the baddies were. The baddies were the evil Catholics who were trying to blow up Parliament. But actually, there's kind of skullduggery and oppression on both sides. But the second reason why it's very Le Carre-esque is that there's a kind of murk, and you're never entirely sure whether the details of how the plot came to be discovered are true.
它确实很复杂，所有好的恐怖阴谋都这样。嗯，这很有勒卡雷的风格。非常勒卡雷。而且它非常有勒卡雷式的风格，我想原因有二。首先，你永远不完全清楚谁是好人，谁是坏人。没错。是的。显然，在17和18世纪以及19世纪的大部分时间里，在英国，谁是坏人是很清楚的。坏人是那些试图炸毁议会的邪恶天主教徒。但事实上，双方都有阴谋诡计和压迫。但它非常具有勒卡雷风格的第二个原因，是这里面有一种混浊感，你永远无法完全确定关于阴谋是如何被发现的细节是否属实。
That's right. Really, whether the entire thing was fabricated or not. I mean, I don't think it was. I think it was absolutely a genuine plot. But it has been argued that it was completely fabricated by Cecil. Yes, the spymaster. James I, the son of Lord Burley, who was Elizabeth I's minister. So it is a kind of thrillingly complicated story.
没错。真的，整件事情到底是捏造的还是怎么回事。我的意思是，我不认为它是捏造的。我认为这绝对是一个真实的阴谋。但也有人争辩说，这完全是塞西尔捏造的。是的，间谍头子。詹姆斯一世，伊丽莎白一世的大臣伯利勋爵的儿子。所以这确实是一个令人惊心动魄、错综复杂的故事。
So let's give a bit of context, first of all. Maybe I'll say a bit about the context. So we're in the late 16th, early 17th century. So England has been through the Reformation. In Elizabeth's reign, there has been this sort of fear of Catholic conspiracy, hasn't there? There's been sort of Fox's Book of Martyrs, which is this huge saga of sort of Protestant martyrs being killed by evil Catholics. There's this sense of Jesuit conspirators flooding into England. I mean, actually, there's not many of them,
所以首先我们来提供一点背景。也许我先讲讲背景。现在是16世纪末、17世纪初。所以英国经历了宗教改革。在伊丽莎白统治时期，有一种对天主教阴谋的恐惧，不是吗？有类似于《福克斯殉道者史》这样的作品，这是一部关于新教殉道者被邪恶天主教徒杀害的宏大传奇。有一种耶稣会阴谋分子涌入英国的感觉。我的意思是，实际上，他们没那么多，
but there's this sort of general paranoia about them. There's this, unbelievably to our sort of 21st century eyes, there's this sense of a kind of evil empire. I think one historian called James Sharp calls it in his book, Remember, Remember. He sort of says, you know, there's this sense of an overarching Catholic conspiracy that involves the King of Spain, the Pope, all kinds of fifth columnists in England. Well, and that's the Le Carre angle as well. And yet the thing is that this isn't completely, this isn't completely mad.
但人们对他们有一种普遍的偏执。在我们的21世纪的眼光看来，这简直难以置信，有一种“邪恶帝国”的感觉。我想历史学家詹姆斯·夏普在他的书《记住，记住》中就是这样称呼它的。他某种程度上说，你知道，有一种笼罩一切的天主教阴谋的感觉，它涉及西班牙国王、教皇以及英国的各种第五纵队。嗯，这也是勒卡雷式的角度。然而问题是，这并不是完全，这并不是完全疯狂。
Of course not, because within Elizabeth's reign, the Spanish Armada had come. Right. And there are Spanish troops across the Channel in the Netherlands. In Flanders. Yeah, exactly. And of course, there's also been a huge massacre of Protestants in Paris in 1572 in the St. Bartholomew's Day Massacre. The Dutch guy, William the Silent, has been assassinated in 1584. And on top of that, perhaps the key thing is in 1570, the Pope Pius V had excommunicated Elizabeth as a heretic and had essentially said that it was the duty of any Catholic to get rid of her, perhaps to assassinate her. And so there was this... So I think understandably,
当然不是，因为在伊丽莎白统治期间，西班牙无敌舰队曾兵临城下。没错。而且西班牙军队驻扎在海峡对岸的尼德兰。在法兰德斯。是的，没错。当然，1572年在圣巴托洛缪节大屠杀中，巴黎还发生过针对新教徒的大屠杀。荷兰人“沉默者威廉”于1584年被暗杀。最重要的是，也许关键的一点是，在1570年，教皇庇护五世将伊丽莎白革除教籍，斥为异端，并基本上表示，任何天主教徒都有责任除掉她，也许是暗杀她。所以这就有了……所以我觉得可以理解的是，
there is jitteriness and paranoia among Elizabeth's regime and among Protestants more generally. And there's this kind of terrible... When the question that's always put to Catholics, the bloody question, whose side would you take if the Bishop of Rome or other prince by his authority
伊丽莎白政权和更广泛的新教徒中间存在着紧张和偏执。并且有一种可怕的……当那个一直抛给天主教徒的问题，那个血淋淋的问题：如果罗马主教或其他亲王以其权威入侵王国并率军前来，你会站在哪一边？这对于一个忠诚的天主教爱国者来说是一个无法回答的问题，因为这完全是分裂的忠诚。我的妻子是天主教徒。我经常问她这个问题。我的妻子也是。你应该，你应该，
should invade the realm by an army, which is a kind of impossible question for a good Catholic and a patriotic Catholic to answer because totally split loyalties. My wife is Catholic. And I often ask her that question. Mine is too. I should, you should,
你应当去问，因为了解这一点很好，你需要了解，你知道的，你可不想发现自己在自己家里窝藏了一个叛徒，托马斯。不，那会很令人震惊，不是吗？但是当然，现在英国没有多少天主教徒了。
you should, because it's good to know you need to know, you know, you don't want to find out that you're harboring a traitor in your own household, Tom. No, that would be shocking, wouldn't it? But of course, so now there aren't many Catholics in England.
大概4万名吧？我的意思是，这非常，非常……那是约翰·博西的估计，他曾是……没错。这极具争议，到底有多少人。北方有一些，在约克郡和兰开夏郡。有一些士绅阶层的天主教徒。所以士绅才是这个故事的关键，不是吗？
What are the 40,000 maybe? I mean, it's very, very... That's the estimate of John Bossie, who was... That's right. That's very contested, exactly how many there are. There are some in the north, in Yorkshire and Lancashire. There are gentry Catholics. So it's the gentry that's the key, isn't it, for this story?
因为基本上，对于不去英国国教会做礼拜的人，会处以巨额罚款。是的，也就是所谓的“不服从国教者”。不服从国教者。所以基本上，信奉天主教变得越来越昂贵。而且，当然，这也是那些拥有宅邸的士绅，他们可以在那里建造神父避难所，建立各种设施，使特别是耶稣会士，以及不仅是耶稣会士，还有从杜埃（为英国神父回国而建立的修道院）远道而来的神父们能够过来。所以他们提供这些。
Because basically there are swinging fines imposed on people who don't go to the Church of England services. Yeah, recusants, as they call it. Recusants. And so essentially, increasingly, it becomes very, very expensive to be a Catholic. And, of course, also it's gentry with houses where they can build priest holes and build up the apparatus that enables particularly the Jesuits, but not only the Jesuits, priests who are coming over from Dowie, which is this kind of seminary that's being built for English priests to go back there. So they provide it.
而这其中的关键人物往往是女性。她们利用了这样一种观点：在政府（即监督人们行为的机构）看来，人们默认男性是一家之主，女性在搞什么名堂则没那么重要。但实际上正是女性在其中带头，呃，她们在为士绅中的各种不服从国教者成员（特别是中部地区的成员）之间建立联系方面发挥了关键作用，而且这是一场以中部地区为核心的阴谋，随着事态发展确实如此。不过托马斯，我也在想，是不是还有这样一种成分：如果你是一个男人，而且来自
And the key figures in this tend to be women. And they kind of leverage the fact that in the opinion of the government, the kind of institutions that patrol how people are behaving, it's assumed that men are the head of the household and it's less significant what women are up to. but actually it's women who are taking the lead in this um and that they play a kind of key role in providing links between the various recusant members of the gentry particularly in the midlands and and it's it's a midland focused conspiracy as it emerges it is i also wonder whether there's an element though tom that if you're a man and you're from
士绅阶层，也就是说，对于不太了解的人来说，你会怎么形容这个？那大约是，比方说，退而求其次的话，相当于上中产阶级。那么你可能会想成为一名律师，或者你可能想成为一名国会议员，或者你可能想成为一名教师之类的人。而作为一个天主教徒，你无法做任何这些事情，因为你必须宣誓效忠。所以基本上，如果你是一个虔诚信仰天主教的人，作为一个男人，除非你宣誓效忠，否则你将被排斥在公共生活之外，许多公共生活之外。现在，关于这些法律，有一点是它们往往执行得不是很严，因为它们取决于某种地方上的执行力度，而且很多地方上的大人物基本上都睁一只眼闭一只眼，他们知道街那头那个天主教徒人很好，你知道的。而且在15世纪90年代——你知道，西班牙无敌舰队来了又走，局势开始缓和，情况稍微有些冷却，所以压力没那么大。而且天主教徒所期待的另一件事，就是伊丽莎白去世的前景。是的。和一个来自……或者也许是一个女王。嗯，有，是的，有一些不确定性。
the gentry, so you're from, I mean, for people who don't know, I mean, how would you describe that? That's sort of, let's say the upper middle class for want of a better phrase. Then you might want to be a lawyer or you might want to be an MP or you might want to be a teacher or one of these things. And you can't do any of those things as a Catholic because you have to swear the oath of supremacy so basically if you're practicing believing Catholic you as a man you are shut out of public life a lot of public life unless you swear the oath now the one thing about these laws is often they're not very harshly
是的，有一些不确定性。所以苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世，苏格兰玛丽女王的儿子（玛丽女王曾是天主教徒，但他本人是作为新教徒抚养长大的），是显而易见的继承人。但还有另一种可能性，就是Infanta（西班牙公主），
enforced because they're dependent on kind of local enforcement and lots of kind of local bigwigs basically turn a blind eye they know the catholic down the road is fine you know and in the 1590s so you know that the spanish armada has come and gone things are starting to ease off um things slightly kind of cool so it's it's less stressful and also the other thing that catholics have to look forward to is the prospect of Elizabeth dying. Yeah. And a new king from... Or perhaps a queen. Well, there's, yes, there's a bit of uncertainty.
她是腓力二世的女儿，英国的天主教徒对她可能会——我想她似乎是冈特的约翰的后代什么的，非常——我想是的——所以他们紧抓着希望不放，要么是Infanta会继承伊丽莎白（那是个遥远的奢望，结果证明行不通），要么是作为玛丽女王的儿子的詹姆斯，会对天主教徒比伊丽莎白更友好。这并没有错，因为詹姆斯，所以詹姆斯，大家经常收听我们的节目。节目之友。好吧，不，詹姆斯是节目之友。
Yeah, there's a bit of uncertainty. So James VI of Scotland, son of Mary Queen of Scots, who was a Catholic, but has himself been raised a Protestant, is the obvious heir. But there is another possibility, the Infanta,
口水直流，舌头大得塞不进嘴里，全基督教世界最聪明的傻瓜。但非常聪明。喜欢神学辩论。而詹姆斯厉害的地方在于他是个加尔文主义者。所以他是个，你知道的，苏格兰加尔文主义者。但他同时也信仰君权神授和绝对君主制。所以他并不热衷于那种极端新教的政治意识形态。而天主教徒则认为，好吧，他的态度有点暧昧。詹姆斯是个渴望团结的人，他想要达成共识。所以也许当他上台时，正如你所说，他母亲是个天主教徒，所以他可能代表着，你知道的，他会放松很多这些法律。还有，呃，
who's the daughter of Philip IIilip ii who catholics in england are very excited the thought that she might i think she's descended from john of gaunt or something like that something very i think yeah so they they are kind of they're clinging to the hope either that the infanta will succeed elizabeth that's that's a long stretch and it turns out not to work or that james as the son of Mary, Queen of Scots, will be more favourable to Catholics than Elizabeth had been. Which is not wrong because James, so James, people regularly listen to us. Friend of the show. Well, no, James is a friend of the show.
那个说詹姆斯是“全基督教世界最聪明的傻瓜”的人是法兰西国王亨利四世。完全正确，所以有两点：他曾是一名新教徒，后来改信了天主教，“巴黎值得一场弥撒”是他对此的名言。但他最终还是被暗杀身亡。是的，没错。谁才是傻瓜？我认为詹姆斯实际上是一个非常精明、非常聪明的操盘手。他做得很出色的一件事，就是保持自己的选择余地。所以，在……在……在……在
Slobbering, tongue too big for his mouth, wisest fool in Christendom. But very smart. Loves a theological debate. And the thing about James is he's a Calvinist. So he's, you know, he's a Scottish Calvinist. But he's also a believer in the divine rights of kings and absolute monarchy. So he is not keen on kind of ultra-Protestant political ideology. And Catholics think, well, he's a bit ambiguous. James is a great man for unity and he wants a consensus. So maybe when he comes in as you say his mother was a catholic so he maybe represents you know he'll relax a lot of these laws and also um the the
伊丽莎白去世前的几个月和几周里，一位杰出的天主教徒托马斯·珀西（我认为他是诺森伯兰伯爵的堂弟，对，他是公爵的一个重要亲戚，是英格兰伟大的贵族之一，实际上统治着北方）前往会见詹姆斯，而詹姆斯则有些含糊其辞，说“行吧，我可能会，我可能会，你知道的，废除《反不重国教法》，可能会让天主教徒合法地做礼拜”，然后托马斯·珀西回来后便传播了这些话，英国的天主教徒愿意相信这一点。因此，他们带着希望的心情期盼着詹姆斯的继位，而当詹姆斯成为英格兰国王并南下时，这种充满希望的心情便破灭了。是的，因为他不会——实际上，如果他真的放松了这些法律，对他来说在政治上会非常愚蠢，我认为，因为他显然要南下。有很多人对此充满怀疑，还有苏格兰恐惧症（如果可以这么说的话）敌意：这个苏格兰家伙就要登场了，他会改变一切吗？显然，起初非常明智的是，他不想
guy who said that james was the wisest fool in christendom was henry the fourth of france well exactly so two points so he'd been a protestant who then becomes a catholic paris is worth the mass is his famous quip about that. But he does, he ends up being assassinated. Yeah, so exactly. Who's the fool there? James is actually, I think, a very smart, smart operator. And one of the things that he does very effectively is to kind of keep his options open yeah so so in the um in in the in in the months and the weeks before
改变一切。还有其他两个阴谋，有几个阴谋，火药阴谋，其中有一个阴谋叫“拜因阴谋”（Bye Plot），比如，一大群天主教徒计划绑架詹姆斯，迫使他放松法律。它是天主教徒搞的吗？我不确定这是天主教徒干的。哦，不是天主教徒吗？不，因为沃尔特·罗利，这里面有两个阴谋。你说得对，其中一个是沃尔特·罗利。
elizabeth's death um a prominent catholic thomas percy who i think is the second cousin of the earl of north yeah he's a big relative of the duke one of the great great kind of nobles in england uh rules the north effectively thomas percy goes up to meet james and james kind of prevaricate says yeah okay i might i might you know get rid of the recusancy laws might might make it legitimate for catholics to worship um and thomas percy comes back and he spreads this and catholics in england want to believe this so they are looking forward to james's accession in a spirit of hope, which that spirit of hope then gets dashed when James becomes King of England and heads south. Yeah, because he's not going to, it would actually have been politically very foolish for him, I think, to have relaxed these laws, because obviously he's coming down south. There's a lot of suspicion and, you know, scotophobic, if that's a word hostility this scottish guy is pitching up is he going to change everything and obviously at first quite sensibly he doesn't want
其中一个，沃尔特·罗利也卷入了。我想他是主要阴谋者之一吧？但是首席耶稣会士亨利·加尼特神父（节目之友，因为我们在《麦克白》那一集里提到过他），我想他对此给予了某种暗示，其中一个阴谋……没错，他确实这么做了。他不知怎么知道了这件事，然后他给了一点暗示。所以詹姆斯因为这些阴谋，比平时更加神经质了。是的，基本上他就是决定不打算顺从他们的心意。而在阴暗的角落里潜伏着，我们有一个问题，来自菲奥娜：
to change everything there is a there are two other plots a couple of plots the gunpowder plot there's a plot called the bi plot for example where a load of catholics have a plan that they'll kind of kidnap james and force him to relax the laws. Is it Catholic? I'm not sure it is Catholics. Oh, is it not Catholics? No, because Walter Raleigh, there are two plots. You're right, there is a Walter Raleigh.
罗伯特·塞西尔在之前的几个月和几周里，是否知情、煽动、促成、鼓励、微笑、心知肚明？我们待会儿可能会谈到这一点。但罗伯特·塞西尔是伊丽莎白伟大的得力干将伯利勋爵的儿子，他基本上是王权背后的权力操纵者。他个子很矮，不是吗？他只有五英尺高。你知道伊丽莎白以前怎么称呼他吗？
One of them, Walter Raleigh is involved in it as well. He's the main plot, I think, isn't he? But the chief Jesuit, Father Henry Garnet, the friend of the show because we mentioned him in the Macbeth episode, I think that he kind of tips the nod on that, one of them that's right he does he's somehow he gets to know about it and he's he he tips the knob so so james because of those plots is is twitchier than he might have been yeah and and basically he just decides that he's he's not going to go with it and lurking in the shadows we have we have a question um from fiona Did Robert Cecil know Instigate, Enable, Encourage, Smile,
她叫他“我的小精灵”。我知道詹姆斯叫他“侏儒”。侏儒。那是些更加直言不讳的时代，不是吗？我宁愿认为……我希望约翰·伯考没有在收听这个播客。所以罗伯特·塞西尔潜伏在背景中。是的。
knowingly in the months and weeks before? We might come to that. But Robert Cecil, who is the son of Lord Burley, Elizabeth's great kind of right-hand man, he essentially is the kind of the power behind the throne. He's very short, isn't he? He's five feet tall. Do you know what Elizabeth used to call him?
他基本上，你知道的，他不想，他想维持现状。而且我认为基本上，中部地区的一群年轻贵族、年轻的士绅阶层成员基本上认为这是一件可怕的事情。而关键人物不是盖伊·福克斯，而是一个叫罗伯特·凯茨比的人。是的，他最初来自沃里克郡，是沃里克郡的士绅，生于1573年。他曾去过——他不是去过海峡对岸的那个神学院吗？然后他回来了，而且基本上，他娶了一个新教徒，他娶了一个新教重臣的女儿。她死了，她死后，他又回到了天主教，但这一次他正在经历激进主义化。是的，这不是很迷人吗？你知道，我们现在读到那么多关于人们激进化并成为恐怖分子的报道。他显然已经被激进化了，但他并不符合21世纪激进分子的模式，我不这么认为，因为他不是……
She called him her little elf. I know that James called him a pygmy. A pygmy. They were more forthright times, weren't they? I like to think that... I hope John Bercow's not listening to this podcast. So Robert Cecil is kind of lurking in the background. Yeah.
他不符合21世纪激进分子的模式，我不认为，因为他来自一个——好吧，我的意思是，他的生活对他来说并不是那么糟糕。我的意思是，他的妻子去世了等等。但是，我的意思是，他有很多优势。他非常具有个人魅力，非常受欢迎。
And he's essentially, you know, he doesn't want, he wants to keep things as they are. And I think essentially that a group of young noblemen, young kind of members of the gentry in the Midlands basically decide that this is a terrible thing. And the key figure not guy forks it's a guy called robert catesby yes he's from warwick show originally warwickshire gentry born in 1573 um he'd been off to do i hadn't he been to this seminary over the
他身边聚集的整群人基本上都是些大男孩。他们有点像勃林顿俱乐部的人。他们确实是。这不是很不寻常吗？他们练击剑，骑马奔驰。我想其中一部分原因，正如你提到的，基本上他们的职业生涯无处可去。而这些人属于那种认为自己的职业生涯
over the channel and then he'd come back um and he's basically he's married a protestant he's married a protestant heiress she died she died then goes back to catholicism but this time he's kind of being radicalized yeah it's fascinating isn't it you know we read so much now about people being radicalized and becoming terrorists um he clearly has been radicalized but he's not he doesn't fit the pattern of the 21st century radicalized person i don't think because he's not, he doesn't fit the pattern of the 21st century radicalised person, I don't think, because he's from a, well, I mean, his life isn't that terrible for him. I mean, his wife has died and stuff. But, I mean, he's got lots going for him. He's very charismatic, very popular.
应该有所成就的类型。因此，他们晋升的希望破灭了。所以我确信这也是其中一个因素。他们碰头，密谋，甚至在酒馆里密谋。我的意思是，那是在哪里？呃，“公爵与德雷克”酒馆，在河岸街，1604年5月20日。所以是凯茨比和我想另外五个人，其中一个是托马斯·珀西。对，所以他将成为托马斯·珀西，他走进来，走进酒馆说：“先生们，难道我们总是只说不做吗？”这也是本播客的座右铭，托马斯。
The whole group that he gets around him are basically, they're kind of massive lads. They're the kind of Bullington Club. They are. That's the extraordinary thing, isn't it? They fence, they gallop. And I think that a part of it is, you know, you mentioned that essentially their careers are going nowhere. And these are the kind of guys who assume that their careers
当我读到这段时，我想，这不就是我和托马斯·霍兰德嘛。但是，我的意思是，这是一种，你知道的，恐怖组织中非常熟悉的说辞。我们谈了又谈，却从不付诸行动。我们从不真正做任何事。这也伴随着那种为了行动而行动的崇拜，因为他们其实并没有一个很好的计划，我是说。所以他们的计划基本上是他们打算在议会开幕式上炸毁议会大厦。所以当时有詹姆斯，有上议院，有下议院，基本上有
should be going somewhere. So their hopes of advancement are frustrated. So I'm sure that's an element they meet they cook it up they even cook it up in the pub i mean where is it the uh the duke and drake in the strand are on the 20th of may 1604 so it's catesby and i think five others um one of whom is is thomas percy yeah so he's gonna be thomas percy and and he comes in and he walks into the pub and he says, shall we always, gentlemen, talk and never do anything? That's the motto of this podcast, Tom.
整个政治建制派将被炸上天。然后空中悬着那个许多听众都问过的问题：他们接下来要做什么？他们的计划是他们要抓住詹姆斯的第三个孩子，也就是伊丽莎白，她当时几岁？八九岁？是的。
When I read that, I thought, that's me and Tom Holland. But, I mean, that's a kind of, you know, that's a very familiar kind of phrase from terrorist groups. Yeah. We talk and talk and talk and never do anything. We never actually do anything. And it's also that sort of worship of the deed for its own sake because they don't really have a very good plan i don't think so their plan is basically they're going to blow up the houses
他们打算去，她在考文垂。天知道为什么，但她在考文垂。你去过考文垂，在你的某次旅行中，太棒了，是的。所以她有点像斯图亚特公主里的托马斯·霍兰德。她在考文垂。他们要上考文垂去，绑架她，然后利用她。但这真的是个太蠢的主意了，这是个糟糕透顶的主意，不是吗？这真的是个糟糕的主意。我的意思是，我在想你会拿它跟什么作对比。
of parliament of the state opening a parliament so you've got james you've got the house of lords you've got the mps you've got basically House of Lords, you've got the MPs, you've got basically the entire political establishment blown sky high. And then there's that question that hangs in the air that lots of our listeners have asked, what are they going to do next? And their plan is they're going to get James's third child, who is Elizabeth, who's what, eight, nine? Yeah.
而且，它比施陶芬贝格阴谋还要糟糕。所以它有点像1944年旨在除掉希特勒的施陶芬贝格阴谋。所以它是斩首领导层，但施陶芬贝格阴谋对于他们如何在柏林夺取权力、接下来要做什么等有很强的切实感知。酒馆里的这些家伙，我觉得他们并没有一个好计划。这也稍微有点像他们有点……这是年轻人对长辈的不耐烦，
They're going to go, she's up in Coventry. God knows why, but she's in Coventry. You've been to Coventry on knows why but she's in coventry you've been to coventry on one of your trips wonderful yeah um so she's sort of tom holland of of stewart princesses she's in coventry they're gonna go up to coventry they're gonna kidnap her and they're gonna use her but i mean it's such a stupid idea it's such a it's a terrible idea isn't it it is a terrible idea i mean i was thinking what you would compare it to. And it's, it's worse than the Stauffenberg plot. So it's a bit like the Stauffenberg plot in the 1944,
这也是你在现在的许多受伊斯兰主义启发的恐怖袭击中看到的情况。你会看到他们的父母说：“我们完全不知情。”当时的情况也差不多。是的。我想即使在当时，托马斯，其中一个人，一个叫托马斯·温特的人，
get rid of Hitler. So it's decapitate the leadership, but the Stauffenberg plot has had a real sense of how they would seize power in Berlin, what they would do next and so on. These guys in the pub, I don't think they have a very good. It's also slightly that they're kind of, it's, it's young men impatient with their elders,
当凯茨比提出这个计划的想法时，他说：“这是一个糟糕的主意。”但正如一群差不多五个小伙子——你知道，年轻小伙子——聚在一起时的经典桥段那样，其他人把他的声音压了下去。他说：“哦，好吧，行吧，我跟你们一起干。”而凯茨比，正如你所说，每个人都说他具有难以置信的个人魅力，极具魅力，以至于他在剧中由基特·哈灵顿（又名琼恩·雪诺）扮演。基特·哈灵顿真的那么有魅力吗？难道他不是有点木讷吗？是的，我觉得他有点木讷。我觉得他配不上凯茨比的魅力。而且凯茨比也有——我的意思是，当他们被问到“我们为什么要炸毁议会”时，他说，
which is also something that you see now with a lot of, say, Islamist-inspired terrorist attacks. You'll get kind of their parents saying, we have no idea. And pretty much the same there. Yeah. I think even at the time, Tom, one of them, a guy called Thomas Winter,
基本上，那是他们做了所有坏事的地方，大意如此。你知道，这是他们在那里……
when Catesby brings up the idea of the pan, he says, this is a terrible idea. But in that classic way that happens when a group of kind of five blokes and, you know, young blokes are together, the others kind of shout him down. He says, oh, OK, fine, I'll go along with it. And Catesby, as you said, everybody says he's unbelievably charismatic, so charismatic that he gets played by Kit Harington, a.k.a. John Snow. Is Kit Harington that charismatic, though, though is he not a trifle wooden yes i thought he was a trifle wooden i i thought he didn't measure up to the charisma of kate's b but also kate's b has i mean so they say why are we going to blow up parliament and he says um basically it's it's the place that they have done all the mischief or something to that effect you know this is the place where they're
把我们踩在脚下的地方。这里面有一种简单性，不是吗？那种东西……我想是吧。这是斯图亚特王朝的一个开始。当然，这个阴谋——现在任何一个好的阴谋故事都需要有一系列的一团糟和一再延误，而你也确实得到了这些。但同时你也需要一个人，
they're doing us down and there's a kind of simplicity to that isn't there kind of stuff i suppose so it was a start in the stuarts but of course the plot as now what you need with any good story of a plot is a series of shambles and delays and you get that yes but also you need someone um presumably if you're going to blow it up with gunpowder you need opportunity and you need someone who knows how to handle gunpowder. So the opportunity comes from the fact that Northumberland, the Earl of Northumberland, is able to pull strings and get Thomas Percy appointed to some kind of honorary position. Gentleman pensioner. A gentleman pensioner. A gentleman pensioner.
如果你打算用火药炸毁它的话，假设你需要机会，你需要一个懂得如何处理火药的人。所以机会来自于诺森伯兰伯爵——诺森伯兰伯爵能够拉拢关系，让托马斯·珀西被任命为一个名誉职位。绅士侍卫。一个绅士侍卫。一个绅士侍卫。
What a great thing to me. Which means that he has ready access to the Houses of Parliament. And that means that he can start bringing in barrels of gunpowder. Yeah. And no one's going to ask questions. And they're not put in a cellar, are they? That's what we always say. It's actually a kind of stable.
对我来说这是多么了不起的事。这意味着他可以轻易进入议会大厦。这意味着他可以开始把一桶桶火药运进去。是的。而且没有人会盘问。而且它们不是放在地窖里，对吧？我们总是这么说。它其实是一个马厩。
I was surprised at that, yeah, when I started my in-depth research. It's actually a ground floor storeroom. But Dominic, who do they employ as their gunpowder expert? Well, he's Guy Orghido-Fawkes, isn't he? Yeah, it is. So he's a Yorkshireman. He's a Yorkshireman. And he's a very dashing fellow, Guy Fawkes.
我很惊讶，是的，当我开始我的深入研究时。它其实是一个底层的储藏室。但是多米尼克，他们雇佣谁作为他们的火药专家呢？嗯，他是盖伊·奥吉多·福克斯，对吧？是的，没错。所以他是个约克郡人。他是个约克郡人。而且他是个非常潇洒的家伙，盖伊·福克斯。
Yeah, he really is. So he came from school in York that is still going strong today, St. Peter's School. And in 1992, the head boy of St. Peter's School said that Guy Fawkes was not exactly a role model. But in a way, he is. So he's born Protestant, becomes Catholic as a boy, I think, and goes off and really makes a name for himself in Flanders, fighting with the Spanish. He's very brave, isn't he?
是的，确实如此。他毕业于约克的一所至今仍在蓬勃发展的学校——圣彼得学校。1992年，圣彼得学校的首席毕业生说，盖伊·福克斯并不是一个好榜样。但在某种程度上，他是。所以他生为新教徒，小时候皈依天主教，我想，然后前往法兰德斯，跟随西班牙人作战并真正崭露头角。他非常勇敢，不是吗？
He's very brave, very charismatic, got a sensational kind of red beard. Big hat. Big hat, all the works. And he gets employed by Catholic conspirators to go to Spain to see if they can persuade Philip III, son of Philip II, who sent the Armada to basically invade England. And the King of Spain says no. But that is when Guy changes his name to Guido. Right.
他非常勇敢，极具魅力，留着一头非常显眼的红胡子。大帽子。大帽子，应有尽有。他被天主教阴谋分子雇佣去西班牙，看看能否说服腓力三世（派遣无敌舰队的腓力二世之子）基本上入侵英格兰。而西班牙国王拒绝了。但正是在那时，盖伊把名字改成了圭多。对的。
I didn't know that because I was puzzled about the... Now, one thing about the gunpowder, an interesting thing, the reason they're able to get there, you were saying about sort of means, motive and opportunity. One reason they're able to get the gunpowder is that England had been at war with Spain. And James, when he became king, basically called it off because he said it's going nowhere. It's a complete waste of time. So actually this gunpowder is on the market and it's cheap. There's no need for it. So they're able to get all this gunpowder and they bring it in.
我不知道这一点，因为我之前对……现在，关于火药，有一件有趣的事，他们能到达那里的原因——你刚才提到手段、动机和机会。他们能够获得火药的原因之一是英国曾与西班牙交战。而詹姆斯当上国王后，基本上取消了这场战争，因为他说这毫无意义。这完全是在浪费时间。所以事实上这些火药在市面上很便宜。根本不需要它。所以他们能够弄到所有这些火药并把它们运进来。
But the gunpowder is there too long. Because there's plague, right? Because so often in 17th century England, 16th, 17th century England, there's a plague. So Parliament gets prorogued. It gets pushed back. So they thought it was going to be earlier. It's like a COVID delay.
但火药放在那里的时间太长了。因为闹瘟疫，对吧？因为在17世纪、16世纪的英国，经常爆发瘟疫。所以议会被休会了。它被推迟了。所以他们以为会更早。这就像新冠疫情导致的延期。
Yeah, exactly. There's been a bit of a lockdown-style scenario. The opening of Parliament is postponed to the 5th of November, 1605. So a lot later than they were hoping. Anyway, the gunpowder just kind of sits there, doesn't it, in this sort of storeroom. Buried beneath wood. Yeah, tons of wood. And you would think, well, why doesn't somebody find it?
是的，完全如此。曾经有过一段类似封城的时期。议会开幕式被推迟到1605年11月5日。所以比他们希望的要晚得多。无论如何，火药就那样放在那里，不是吗，在这个储藏室里。埋在木头下面。是的，几吨木头。你会想，为什么没有人发现它呢？
But the Palace of Westminster and that complex is a completely different beast from what there is today. It's just this great rambling, sprawling mess of buildings and there's no security. You know, there's people going in and out all the time. The storerooms are full of clutter. So it's completely understandable why nobody detects all this. And then you get this letter. Now, this is such an interesting story. The Mont Eagle letter. Yes so mont eagle is is a nobleman with catholic sympathies yeah i think that's right is he a catholic himself i can't
但威斯敏斯特宫及其建筑群与今天的完全不同。它只是一团杂乱无章、庞大散漫的建筑，而且没有安保。你知道，人们随时进进出出。储藏室里堆满了杂物。所以完全可以理解为什么没有人察觉到这一切。然后你收到了这封信。现在，这是一个非常有趣的故事。蒙蒂格尔勋爵的信。是的，所以蒙蒂格尔是一位有天主教同情心的贵族。是的，我想是的，他自己是天主教徒吗？我记不清了，但他有点像是在游离，
remember but he's he's kind of he's he's floating basically he's floating around on the edge of of catholic conspiracies that's right i think he had been a catholic and now possibly and i think i i think he's like the earl of northumberland who is catholic in his heart right say yeah um so he shortly before uh parliament is due to open um his servant comes in says he's he's been handed a letter by a mysterious figure and this letter when it's deciphered um says you should you should keep away from parliament they shall receive a terrible blow, this Parliament. Terrible blow. And yet they shall not see who hurts them.
基本上他在天主教阴谋的边缘游离。没错，我想他以前是个天主教徒，现在可能……而且我认为他就像诺森伯兰伯爵一样，内心深处是个天主教徒，对吧？所以，在议会即将开幕前不久……他的仆人进来，说他被一个神秘人物交了一封信，这封信经破译后说：“你们应该，你们应该远离议会，这个议会将遭受一次可怕的打击。可怕的打击。然而他们却看不见是谁伤害了他们。”
And Monteagle takes it to Robert Cecil, who by this point has become the Earl of Salisbury. Yeah. Good to see Salisbury getting a name check. Good to see Salisbury. So I'm all over him. And Cecil takes it to james uh and so it is that um people are sent down to uh to inspect and they find the gunpowder and they find a shadowy figure but they don't at first though
蒙蒂格尔把信交给了罗伯特·塞西尔，此时他已成为索尔兹伯里伯爵。是的。很高兴看到索尔兹伯里榜上有名。很高兴看到索尔兹伯里。所以我对他全盘了解。塞西尔把信拿给詹姆斯看，于是……人们被派去……去视察，然后他们找到了火药，找到了一个神秘人物，但他们一开始并没有……
no they inspect it first and they don't see it they say it was just a load of old wood who cares yeah fine or do they i mean this is all part of the Le Carre Merc. Are they waiting so that they can capture the people responsible? Yeah, because they say at the time they see a tall and very desperate fellow. But they're like, oh, it's fine. There's probably nothing wrong with it. And then James says, well, again, this is unclear. The propaganda basically says, James says, no, no, go back and check again.
不，他们先去视察了，但他们没有看见。他们说那只是一堆旧木头，谁在乎呢？对吧，挺好的。或者他们真的看到了？我的意思是，这都是勒卡雷式的阴谋诡计的一部分。他们是在等待以便抓获负责任的人吗？是的，因为他们当时看到一个身材高大、极其绝望的家伙。但他们觉得，哦，没关系。可能没什么问题。然后詹姆斯说——嗯，同样，这并不清楚。宣传基本上说，詹姆斯说：“不，不，回去再检查一遍。”
In a Scottish accent. And back they go. So it's the sort of early hours of the 5th of November, a Scottish accent and um back they go so it's the sort of early hours of the 5th of November isn't it when back they go and they find a booted cloaked hatted figure with three fuses yeah called John Johnson good alias who is he he's Guy Fawkes oh my goodness you've blown it Dominic um well I mean unlike Guy Fawkes ironically um yeah so they find guy fawkes and uh and of course so much of this could be untrue right that's what's so fascinating so go back to the letter yeah it's often thought that the letter is sent to lord i mean the letter is such a dopey thing to do sent to lord mount eagle by his brother-in-law francis tresham who's one of the conspirators
带着苏格兰口音。然后他们回去了。所以那是11月5日的清晨，带着苏格兰口音……他们回去了，然后他们发现了一个穿着靴子、披着斗篷、戴着帽子的人物，身上带着三个引信，自称约翰·强森（一个好化名）。他是谁？他是盖伊·福克斯。哦，天哪，你把事情搞砸了，多米尼克。好吧，我的意思是，和盖伊·福克斯不同，讽刺的是……是的，所以他们找到了盖伊·福克斯。而且，这一切中有那么多可能是假的，对吧？这就是最迷人的地方。所以回到那封信，它通常被认为这封信是寄给……我的意思是，这封信是弗朗西斯·特雷瑟姆（阴谋分子之一，对此一直很不情愿，不想让他的内兄被炸飞，并表达了保留意见）通过他的连襟寄给蒙蒂格尔勋爵的愚蠢举动。
and who's been very reluctant about it yeah who doesn't want his brother-in-law, Francis Tresham, who's one of the conspirators. And who's been very reluctant about it. Yeah, who doesn't want his brother-in-law to get blown up. And express reservations. But some people say that this may not be the case, that Lord Mount Eagle may have dictated the letter himself. So Antonia Fraser, who's written the great narrative account of the gunpowder plot, that's her thesis. And is that because she thinks Tresham has told Mount Eagle personally and they just want to find a way for Mount Eagle to yeah to pass it
但有些人说情况可能并非如此，蒙蒂格尔勋爵可能自己口授了这封信。因此，安东尼娅·弗雷泽（她写了关于火药阴谋的宏大叙事账目）就是她的论点。这是因为她认为特雷瑟姆私下告诉了蒙蒂格尔，他们只是想找个办法让蒙蒂格尔……去把信转交出去，基本上，如果蒙蒂格尔因为一直处于阴谋的边缘而知道了这件事，他需要掩盖自己的后路，以便解释他是如何知道这个阴谋的。
on basically that if that if Mount Eagle knows about it because he's been on the edge of the conspiracy um he needs to kind of cover his back yeah so that he can explain how it is that he knows about the uh about the conspiracy and this. And the letter is crucial to the whole story that then gets revealed to a shell-shocked Protestant nation about what's been going on. So it's really, he gets a pension, all kinds of things. So you can't in any way have Mount Eagle being kind of fingered as a suspect.
而这封信对于向一个惊魂未定、刚刚经历这一切的新教国家揭示所发生的事情至关重要。所以，他得到了养老金和各种好处。因此，你绝不能让蒙蒂格尔被当作嫌疑人指指点点。
But also that letter is the 26th of October and they wait and wait and wait the authorities before pouncing at the very last minute. And so ever since, lots of people have said, do they wait and wait and wait? Because Robert Cecil is basically looking for the most melodramatic possible story to tell to the public. Does he know about it? Or indeed, did he devise the plot? Was it a kind of false flag operation? I mean, I think no, but I think it's entirely plausible that he may have scoped out the fact. And this is, you mentioned about the delay. Yeah. That the gunpowder had been there for quite a few months.
而且这封信是10月26日的，当局在发起突袭前等待、等待、再等待，直到最后一分钟。所以从那时起，很多人一直在说，他们为什么一直在等待？因为罗伯特·塞西尔基本上是在寻找最扣人心弦、最耸人听闻的故事来讲给公众听。他是知情的吗？或者事实上，是他策划了这个阴谋？这是一次虚假旗帜行动吗？我的意思是，我认为没有，但我认为完全有可能他曾经暗中探查过情况。而且——你提到了延期。
Basically, it turns out that the plot would never have worked because the gunpowder had decayed. So it was not such a good story. Is it when you, nothing happens. No. And so perhaps, you know, it's,
基本上，事实证明这个阴谋永远不会成功，因为火药已经受潮失效了。所以这并不是一个多好的故事，当事情发生时，什么也没发生。不。所以也许，你知道的，
I mean, totally feasible that Cecil had, had, had checked it out and realized that there wasn't any danger. And therefore it was absolutely fine to leave it there and they could catch them all red handed. Although Tom, the counter argument to that is that what's in it for Cecil to cook this up,
我的意思是，塞西尔完全有可能调查过并意识到没有任何危险。因此，把火药留在那儿完全没问题，他们可以当场人赃俱获。不过托马斯，对此的反对意见是，塞西尔费尽心机策划这出戏，对他有什么好处呢？
because it's not like he uses the gunpowder plot for some hideous crackdown on Catholics. You know, it's not a kind of rice stag fire kind of event, is it? I mean, they don't use it, I guess, politically at Rallis support for the regime. But it doesn't it's not like he can use this for some repressive purpose of his own. Yes. I mean, also, well,ames's key interest at the moment when this happens is is uh forging a union between england scotland that's his focus he's not really interested in issues about catholics or whatever um so it it has been argued that cecil who was more interested in that might have used it to try and get james back on track and so that's very good at um you
因为他并没有利用火药阴谋对天主教徒进行可怕的镇压。你知道，这并不是像圣巴托罗缪节大屠杀那样的事件，对吧？我的意思是，他们并没有在政治上利用它来巩固对政权的拥护。但事情也并非如此，好像他可以为了自己的某种镇压目的而利用这件事。是的。我的意思是，同时，詹姆斯在这个事件发生时的核心关键利益是促成英格兰和苏格兰的联合，这才是他的重点，他其实并不关心天主教徒之类的问题……所以，有人认为，对那方面更感兴趣的塞西尔可能利用了这件事，试图让詹姆斯重回正轨，所以这在……
know he takes the letter to james and allows james to decipher it and pretend that he's worked it out yeah so settle plays a very kind of astute game here um but we don't know and that's that that is part of the fascination of it uh you know who are the who who's deceiving who who who who who whose plot is it essentially um and i think i think we should take a break here. And when we come back, we should look at what happens after John Johnson, a.k.a. Guy Fawkes. I gave it away. I'm gutsy with myself now.
你知道，他把信件拿给詹姆斯，让詹姆斯去破译，然后假装是詹姆斯自己破解的，是的，所以塞西尔在这里玩了一场非常精明的手腕，但我们并不知道，这也是它的魅力所在，你知道，到底是谁在欺骗谁，到底是谁、谁、谁、谁的阴谋呢，本质上，我认为我们应该在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，我们应该看看约翰·约翰逊（又名盖伊·福克斯）被捕之后发生了什么。我剧透了。我现在对自己有点无所畏惧了。
You did, you did, you did, you did. I mean, no one would have known before this. And then look at the reverberations of the plot right the way through the centuries up to the present day. Splendid. We shall see you fireworks in hand after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
你确实剧透了，确实，确实，确实。我的意思是，在这之前没有人会知道。然后看看这个阴谋的余波一直延续了几个世纪，直到今天。太棒了。休息过后，我们将带着烟花与您见面。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》。这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝不苟的八卦。而在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. This is a 5th of November Guy Fawkes Bonfire Night special. And in the first half, we left the scene absolutely hanging. John Johnson, a.k.a. Guy Fawkes, has been discovered.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家剧集和提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史而已》。这是11月5日盖伊·福克斯篝火之夜特别节目。在上半场节目中，我们将现场气氛完全留在了悬念之中。约翰·约翰逊，也就是盖伊·福克斯，已经被发现了。
He gets taken to the Tower of London, where he is tortured to try and find out his identity. He's incredibly, I mean, he's very, very brave. He holds out for a long time. And in the meanwhile, however, Cecil's agents are going out there. They're kind of working out what's been going on. And immediately on the 5th of November, an arrest warrant is issued for Thomas Percy, who it is said on this arrest warrant, privy to one of the most horrible treasons that ever was contrived. And while Guy Fawkes is being tortured in the Tower of London, Percy, Catesby, various others of the conspirators are galloping northwards. Parliament hasn't blown up, but they are still committed to trying to seize Princess Elizabeth. Yeah. So this is an element of shambles, isn't it? Just on Guy Fawkes being tortured, you know what he, of course, he says to James, he says, I want to blow all you Scots back to Scotland.
他被带到伦敦塔，在那里遭受酷刑以查明他的身份。他极其……我的意思是，他非常非常勇敢。他坚持了很长一段时间。然而与此同时，塞西尔的特工们正在四处出击。他们正在弄清到底发生了什么，并且在11月5日当天，立即对托马斯·珀西发出了一份逮捕令，逮捕令上称他参与了“有史以来最可怕的叛国罪之一”。正当盖伊·福克斯在伦敦塔遭受酷刑时，珀西、卡茨比以及其他几名同谋正骑马向北狂奔。议会虽然没有被炸毁，但他们仍然致力于试图绑架伊丽莎白公主。是的。所以这是一个混乱的元素，对吧？就在盖伊·福克斯遭受酷刑时，你知道他当然对詹姆斯说了什么，他说，我想把你们这群苏格兰人全都炸回苏格兰。
He does. Yes. And we've got a question here on that from Annie Scott. Did Guy Fawkes hate the Scots? If so, why? And if he was certain that the two nations could not be reconciled for long, is he a most unlikely champion for Scottish independence? He did hate the Scots.
他是这么说的。是的。关于这一点，我们收到了安妮·斯コット（Annie Scott）的一个问题。盖伊·福克斯讨厌苏格兰人吗？如果是，为什么？如果他确信这两个国家不可能长久和解，那么他是苏格兰独立最不可能的拥护者吗？他确实讨厌苏格兰人。
Did he hate the Scots? That's very strong. He said there is a natural host independence? He did hate the Scots. Did he hate the Scots? That's very strong. He said there is a natural hostility between the English and the Scots. All right, fair enough. Well, I mean, probably a lot of, I mean, some listeners would probably agree with him. He was very, very scotophobic. Right. And as you said, yes, he told his Scottish inquisitors that he wanted to blow them back to Scotland.
他讨厌苏格兰人吗？这个说法太强烈了。他说，苏格兰独立吗？他确实讨厌苏格兰人。他讨厌苏格兰人吗？这个说法太强烈了。他说，英格兰人和苏格兰人之间存在着一种天生的敌意。好吧，那倒也是。好吧，我的意思是，可能很多……我的意思是，一些听众可能会赞同他的观点。他非常非常仇视苏格兰人。没错。正如你所说，是的，他告诉他的苏格兰审讯官，他想把他们炸回苏格兰。
Anyway, sorry, I sidetracked you. You were talking about them. So, yeah, this is an interesting thing, and this comes to the counterfactual element that lots of people have asked about. What would have happened if the plotters had succeeded? Because actually the conspirators, as they ride across the country, at first they don't tell people it's failed.
不管怎样，抱歉，我打断你了。你刚才在谈论他们。所以，是的，这是一个有趣的事情，这就引出了许多人一直在询问的反事实元素。如果阴谋成功了会发生什么？因为实际上，当同谋者骑马穿过乡村时，起初他们并没有告诉人们计划已经失败。
They sort of say, hurrah. They race the country. They try to race the country. And obviously, you know, there's this dreadful sort of sequence of events where they're riding to various country houses and banging on the door will you rise up and join us people was like no go away shut the door on their faces yeah so they end up basically doing this peregrine tom holland style peregrination across the midlands of england where they they don't get to coventry don't they pitch up near dudley uh stourbridge very i mean i as a man of the West Midlands,
他们有点像在大喊：万岁。他们在全国各地奔跑。他们试图在全国各地奔跑。显而易见，你知道，这是一连串可怕的事件：他们骑马到各个乡间别墅，疯狂敲门，问“你们愿意起义加入我们吗？”，而人们的反应则是“不，走开”，直接把门在他们脸前关上，是的。所以他们最后基本上是在英格兰中部地区进行了一场这种帕里格林（Peregrine）式的、汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）风格的朝圣之旅，他们没有到达考文垂，对吧？他们在达德利、斯托尔桥附近停了下来，呃……我的意思是，作为一个西米德兰兹人，
I have to say a slightly unglamorous location. Possibly it was more glamorous then. Maybe. They're a place called Hull Beach House in the end, aren't they, in Staffordshire on the 8th of November near Dudley. And there, there is an explosion. Yeah, there's all kinds of stuff. They accidentally set off some gunpowder.
我必须说这是一个稍微不够迷人的地方。可能当时它更迷人一些吧。也许吧。他们最后到达了一个叫霍尔比奇庄园（Holbeche House）的地方，对吧，在11月8日斯塔福德郡达德利附近。在那里，发生了一场爆炸。是的，有各种各样的东西。他们不小心引爆了一些火药。
And I think some of them get killed, some of them get injured. And then there's all kinds of stuff they accidentally set off some gunpowder and i think some of them get killed some of them get injured um and then there's a massive shootout there's a very wild west style shootout wild west shootout uh and there's a there's one of the um the guys who come to arrest them with a single bullet shoots both percy and catesby but catesby you know how he dies now i i find this too good to be true. He supposedly dies clutching with, he's got a crucifix, and he's cradling a picture of the Virgin Mary. Yeah. I think that's maybe, I mean, maybe real, real experts on this will say,
我想他们中的一些人被炸死了，一些人受伤了。然后有各种各样的东西，他们不小心引爆了一些火药，我想他们中的一些人被炸死了，一些人受伤了，然后发生了一场激烈的枪战，这是一场非常美国西部风格的枪战，美国西部风格的枪战，然后有一个前来逮捕他们的家伙，用一颗子弹同时击中了珀西和卡茨比，但卡茨比……你知道他是怎么死的吗？现在，我觉得这好得有点令人难以置信。据说他死的时候紧紧抓着一个十字架，怀里抱着一幅圣母玛利亚的画像。是的。我觉得这可能……我的意思是，也许真正研究这个的专家会说，
no, this is absolutely true, but that seems too good to be true for me. It's a very Hollywood kind of ending, isn't it? Well, Catesby's death basically means that we, it's because Catesby dies dies that we know you know that the shadow so much remains in shadow yeah because he was the he was the kind of the motor the inspiration the organizer of the entire plot so that is why it then becomes all the more important for the inquisitors to work out from from guy forks what's been going on and he holds out very very bravely um but he gets broken um you're not supposed to torture people are you it's against the common law yeah but they do anyway and to be fair uh the protestant authorities
不，这绝对是真的，但在我看来，这好得有点不真实。这是一种非常好莱坞式的结局，对吧？嗯，卡茨比的死基本上意味着我们，正是因为卡茨比死了，我们才知道，你知道，这团阴影依然笼罩了那么久，是的，因为他是整个阴谋的推动者、灵感来源和组织者。所以这就是为什么审讯官们从盖伊·福克斯那里弄清到底发生了什么变得更加重要。他非常非常勇敢地坚持了下来，但他最终还是被击垮了……你不应该虐待别人，对吧？这违反了普通法。是的，但他们还是这么做了。而且平心而论，
are very very twitchy about it because um the accusation against the catholic powers in Europe is that they torture whereas free-born Englishmen don't torture people. But with this, they make an exception. And you can be manacled. So you basically hang from your wrists and slowly get stretched. And then you go on the rack. And everyone is always broken on the rack. And by the end, I mean, famously, Guy Fawkes has a kind of swaggering signature to begin with and
新教当局对此感到非常非常紧张，因为对欧洲天主教势力的指控是他们会使用酷刑，而土生土长的英格兰人是不会虐待犯人的。但对于这件事，他们破例了。你可以被戴上镣铐。所以你基本上是靠手腕悬挂，然后慢慢被拉伸。然后你会被绑上刑具。每个人在刑具上最终都会被折磨得骨骼碎裂。到了最后，我的意思是，众所周知，盖伊·福克斯一开始的签名带着一种狂妄自大的气势，而
by the end it's just a kind of broken squiggle yeah and then um so they they're put on trial there's eight survivors left aren't they they're put on trial in january 1606 the presiding judge is sir edward cook who's the great father of the common law and um you know he makes sure that the whole thing is is blown into this wider conspiracy that the jesuits are behind and he he sure that the whole thing is blown into this wider conspiracy, that the Jesuits are behind. He says in the course of the prosecution that people will find this an extraordinary story, that people will not – they won't believe it could ever have happened.
到了最后，它只剩下了一种破碎的歪扭线条。是的。然后，呃……所以他们被送上法庭，还剩八名幸存者，对吧？他们在1606年1月受审，主审法官是爱德华·科克爵士（Sir Edward Coke），他是普通法的伟大奠基人，呃，你知道的，他确保了整起事件被放大为这是一场更广泛的阴谋，背后有耶稣会在主使。他确保了整起事件被放大为这是一场更广泛的阴谋，背后有耶稣会在主使。他在公诉过程中表示，人们会觉得这是一个非同寻常的故事，人们不会——他们不会相信这竟然真的发生过。
Yeah, but he clearly does believe it happened. Well, at least he purports to believe it's happened. So they're sentenced to be hanged, drawn courted we all know what that means hanged brought down mutilated your privy parts are cut off and burned we haven't had some genital mutilation for a while so no luckily for guy forks he's been so you know ravaged by torture that he dies straight pretty much straight away he breaks his neck so he so four of them get get hanged by st paul's um and the other four get hanged actually in in parliament by in in westminster the yard westminster yard outside parliament uh and i i think guy forks yeah he breaks his neck yeah so he dies on the on the scaffold and then there's a further which
是的，但他显然相信这发生了。嗯，至少他假装相信这发生了。所以他们被判处绞刑、剖腹并示众。我们都知道这意味着什么：绞死、放下、肢解，你的生殖器被割下并烧毁。我们已经有一段时间没有进行过生殖器切除手术了，所以……不过幸运的是，对于盖伊·福克斯来说，他已经被酷刑折磨得不成人形，所以他基本上当场就死了，他摔断了颈椎，所以……他们中有四人在圣保罗教堂外被绞死，另外四人在议会大楼、威斯敏斯特码头……议会外的威斯敏斯特码头被绞死。我想盖伊·福克斯，是的，他摔断了颈椎，是的，所以他在绞刑架上死了。然后还有一次进一步的……
we talked a further uh execution which we talked about um in the macbeth episode which is henry garnett the uh the head of the jesuits in in england who gets arrested um interrogated sentenced uh harmed or uncourtered uh and the question with him that that also is kind of unclear is the degree to which he was involved because he he does know about he knew about it he he gets he says it's it's the it's the uh it's the confessional he can't reveal it uh and he says that he has tipped off you know people in rome the pope to try and to try and stop it um but against that there's the fact that uh he you know
我们讨论过的另一次处决，我们在《麦克白》那一集里讨论过，那就是亨利·加尼特（Henry Garnet），英格兰耶稣会士领袖，他被逮捕、审讯、判刑、开膛破肚。对于他，同样有些不太清楚的问题是，他参与的程度究竟有多深，因为他确实知道这件事，他事先知情。他说这是……这是……这是告解圣事，他不能透露。并且他说他曾向罗马的教皇通风报信，试图阻止这一切。但与此相对的是，他……
he had tipped off um the authorities about the earlier plot when james came to the throne counts for nothing that's um you got to keep doing it you got to keep tipping off you can't tip off and then stop tipping off yeah so it's it's it's it's unclear so there's a lot of murk there but what's interesting though right is that what i found fascinating was that um james himself who who was the you know the the projected target he does not inflate this afterwards into a general attack on catholic he doesn't so he gives a speech to parliament on the 9th of november and he says um you know no foreign power was involved in this you know he doesn't take the opportunity i suppose because he's just concluded peace with sp. So he thinks, well, I'm not going to stir things up again.
曾向当局透露过詹姆斯即位初期的早期阴谋，这毫无用处。那是……你得一直这样做，你得不断通风报信，你不能报信一次然后就停止通风报信。所以这……这……这……并不清楚，因此其中有很多含糊不清的地方。不过有趣的是，对吧，让我着迷的是，詹姆斯本人，作为（你知道的）被预定的目标，事后并没有把这件事夸大为针对天主教徒的全面袭击。他没有这样做。所以他在11月9日向议会发表了一次演讲，他说，你知道的，没有外国势力卷入其中，你知道的，他没有借此机会……我想是因为他刚刚与西班牙缔结了和平。所以他想，好吧，我不会再把事情搞大了。
But also he goes out of his way to say, you know, most English Catholics are just a bit misguided. They're very loyal. They wouldn't, you know, they wouldn't be party to any of this. So in that, rather like George Bush after 9-11, desperate not to blame it on American Muslims. But unlike George Bush, in that Bush, of course, does blame it on on on yeah american muslims but unlike george bush in that bush of course does blame it on foreign power um yes but he's kind of interesting this is not true catholicism he doesn't do that he doesn't do that you know catholicism is a religion of peace he doesn't go into that no no but he and i mean i think it's worth asking it i mean i think that's impressive because the the the scale of what was being plotted really was horrific.
而且他还特意指出，你知道的，大多数英格兰天主教徒只是有点误入歧途。他们非常忠诚。他们不会，你知道的，他们不会参与任何这种事情。所以在这个意义上，有点像9·11事件之后的乔治·布什，极力不想把它归咎于美国穆斯林。但与乔治·布什不同的是，布什当然把这件事归咎于……
So we've got a question from Simon Girdleston. Has anyone ever worked out if the gunpowder had gone off, how big the explosion would have been? The answer to that question is very unexpected, isn't it, Tom? It's very unexpected indeed. It's a top historian who you wouldn't necessarily, who you wouldn't predict. Top historian, it's top gear. It's top gear's Richard Hammond,
是的，但他很有趣，这不是真正的天主教。他没有那样做。他没有那样做，你知道，天主教是一个和平的宗教，他没有扯到那上面去。不，不。但我和……我的意思是，我认为这很值得探讨。我的意思是，我认为这令人印象深刻，因为当时密谋的规模确实令人毛骨悚然。
who in the ITV special gunpowder plot, exploding the legend, got experts in to work that out. And the answer was, it would have blown everything up. So it would have blown up the House of Parliament, Westminster Hall, Westminster Abbey would have come crashing down. So it would have blown up the house of parliament uh westminster hall westminster abbey would have come crashing down so it would have been absolute carnage um it's 36 barrels of gunpowder i mean that's a lot that's a lot yeah if it had gone off but of course it was never going to go off but if they got their way we're talking about hundreds certainly hundreds of people um and not just the great and the good either i mean this is where your sort of 9-11 comparison comes in you know there would have been all kinds of servants
所以我们有一个来自西蒙·格尔德尔斯通（Simon Girdleston）的问题。有没有人计算过，如果火药真的爆炸了，威力会有多大？这个问题的答案非常出人意料，对吧，汤姆？确实非常出人意料。这是一位顶级历史学家，你未必能猜到。顶级历史学家，是《Top Gear》的理查德·汉蒙德（Richard Hammond）。
guards the carnage would have been absolutely people scurrying about with petitions passers-by sightseers you know traders yeah all these kinds of people which in turn then then begs the obvious question which um simon james jones asked if it had been successful would it have initiated the catholic revolution um and he correctly says he attempts to create one despite the plot failure suggests there was no appetite for it and then simon hodge what's the hope of some kind of catholic seizure of power if the plot had succeeded realistic or even plausible i usually assume success would just have meant even worse repression afterwards this is what so the person who's actually dealt with this in a really nice essay on the bbc website is our previous guest professor ronald hudson and he goes into this and he says well we know because the plotters wrote about the
他在ITV的特别节目《火药阴谋：粉碎传奇》中，请来专家计算了结果。答案是，它会炸毁一切。所以它会炸毁议会大厦、威斯敏斯特大厅，威斯敏斯特修道院也会轰然倒塌。所以它会炸毁议会大厦、威斯敏斯特大厅、威斯敏斯特修道院也会轰然倒塌，所以那将是一场绝对的血腥大屠杀。那是36桶火药，我的意思是，那很多，那很多。如果它真的爆炸了。但当然，它本来就不可能爆炸。但如果让他们得逞，我们谈论的是数百人，绝对是数百人。
countryside saying that the plot had worked and nobody rose up so even if the plot had worked the same would have happened they would have written about the countryside and people would not have risen up and actually he says i think utterly plausibly what would have happened is in the hours and days after the plot there would have been a colossal and very bloody repression of english catholics and the person who would have become king because henry the prince of wales uh charismatic protestant here protestant hero already he would have died in the explosion, which would have left James's younger son, Charles, to become Charles I.
而且不仅仅是名流贵族，我的意思是，这就是你的9·11类比派上用场的地方，你知道的，会有各种各样的仆人、卫兵，那场大屠杀绝对会是……人们带着请愿书四处奔跑、路人、观光客、商贩，所有这些形形色色的人。而这反过来又引出了一个显而易见的问题，西蒙·詹姆斯·琼斯（Simon James Jones）曾问过：如果阴谋成功了，它会引发天主教革命吗？他正确地指出，尽管阴谋失败了，但他试图制造一场革命的举动表明，当时并没有这种社会需求。接着是西蒙·霍奇（Simon Hodge）的问题：如果阴谋成功了，天主教夺取政权的希望现实吗，甚至是可信的吗？我通常认为成功只会意味着事后更严厉的镇压。这就是为什么……在BBC网站上一篇非常精彩的文章中真正探讨过这个问题的，是我们的前嘉宾罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）教授。他深入探讨了这一点并指出，好吧，我们知道，因为阴谋分子在骑马穿过乡间时曾写信说阴谋成功了，但并没有人起义。所以即使阴谋成功了，同样的事情也会发生。他们会写信给乡间，而人们依然不会起义。而且事实上，他指出——我认为极其可信——将会发生的是，在阴谋发生后的数小时和数天内，将会对英格兰天主教徒进行一场惨烈而血腥的大镇压。而那个本该成为国王的人——因为威尔士亲王亨利，这位极具个人魅力的英格兰新教英雄，当时已经会在爆炸中丧生——这将留下詹姆斯的幼子查尔斯，让他成为查尔斯一世。
As he later, much later does in reality. But a very different reign, a very different person. So Ronald Hutton suggests, again, it seems to be completely plausibly that Charles, growing up against the background of this attack, this murder of his family, would have become both an absolutist, which in a sense, Charles did, but a radical Protestant absolutist, which would have got the radical Puritan opinion that in due course, go to war with him and end up putting him on the block, would absolutely got, he'd have generated enormous
正如他后来在现实中很久以后所做的那样。但那将是一个截然不同的统治，一个截然不同的人。所以罗纳德·赫顿再次暗示，这似乎完全合乎情理：查尔斯在遭受这种袭击、这种谋杀其家人的背景下长大，将会变成一个专制君主——从某种意义上说，查尔斯确实如此——但同时也会是一个激进的新教专制君主，这将激发出激进的清教徒舆论，最终导致与他开战并把他送上断头台，绝对会激发巨大的……
radical Protestant enthusiasm. And there would have been a kind of absolutist Protestant regime. And then Hutton suggests there would, in the long run, have been a revolution. Yeah, it's great. I love a bit of counterfactual history. Yeah, I love a bit of counterfactual. Even though we dissed it in our counterfactual episode, but we reserve the right to change our minds when Ronald Hudson is involved. So yes.
激进的新教狂热。并且将会产生一种专制的新教政权。然后赫顿暗示，从长远来看，将会发生一场革命。是的，太棒了。我喜欢反事实历史。是的，我喜欢反事实。尽管我们在反事实那一集里对它贬低了一番，但当罗纳德·赫顿参与其中时，我们保留改变想法的权利。所以是的。
And what's also interesting about this? So that's the plot. That's the counterfactual. Now the commemoration. The commemoration, the movement to commemorate it starts straight away. So January 1606, a fellow called Sir Edward Montagu,
关于这个还有什么有趣的地方呢？这就是阴谋。这就是反事实。现在是纪念活动。纪念活动，即纪念它的运动，立刻就开始了。所以1606年1月，一个叫爱德华·蒙塔古爵士（Sir Edward Montagu）的家伙，
he introduces a bill for public thanksgiving, and they say, let's have an annual service. And that annual service of thanksgiving remains in the prayer book for 250 years or so, until 1859, and is then shamefully, in my view, taken out. Is that where it all went wrong for the Church of England? Yeah, absolutely it is. I mean, I think it should have been every month frankly not every year um anyway they uh so yes so straight away but what's interesting is that the beginning i mean they do have so things they often had bells and bonfires and things like that in the 17th century but guy forks is not part of
他提出了一项关于全国感恩的法案，他们说，让我们设立一个年度宗教仪式吧。而那个年度感恩仪式在祈祷书中保留了大约250年，直到1859年，然后在依我看来非常可耻的情况下被取消了。这就是英国国教会一切开始出错的地方吗？是的，绝对是。我的意思是，坦白说，我认为它本该每个月都举行，而不是每年一次。不管怎样，他们……所以是的，立刻就开始了。但有趣的是，一开始——我的意思是，他们确实有——所以在17世纪，他们经常有钟声、篝火之类的东西，但盖伊·福克斯并不是……
the story really at that stage indeed not part of the story for a very long time well the thing the thing i love about the commemorations is is that um charles i obviously you know he he fights civil war head gets chopped off you get the protectorate um and and so many of the kind of traditional Christian festivals punctuate the year get banned. But Boniface Knight doesn't. So throughout the Protectorate, they're celebrating the escape of Charles I's father, the king, from people who wanted to kill him, which is kind of fabulous.
这个故事的一部分，至少在那个阶段还不是。事实上，在很长一段时间里都不是。好吧，我喜欢纪念活动的一点是，查尔斯一世显然，你知道的，他引发了英国内战，脑袋被砍掉了，你有了护国公时期，许多传统基督教节日一年到头都被禁止了。但篝火之夜却没有。所以在整个护国公时期，人们都在庆祝查尔斯一世的父亲——那位国王——从想要杀死他的人手中逃脱，这简直太棒了。
But even at that stage, they have fireworks and they have bonfires. Yes, they do. Peep sees them, doesn't he? Well, Peep's in 1660. I mean, obviously you that stage, they have fireworks. And they have bonfires. Yes, they do. Peeps sees them, doesn't he? Well, Peeps. So Peeps in 1660. I mean, obviously, you can see where they do it in 1660. The monarchy has been restored.
但即便在那个阶段，他们也有烟花和篝火。是的，他们确实有。佩皮斯（Pepys）看到了他们，对吧？好吧，佩皮斯在1660年。我的意思是，很明显，你在那个阶段，他们有烟花。还有篝火。是的，他们确实有。佩皮斯看到了他们，对吧？好吧，佩皮斯。所以佩皮斯在1660年。我的意思是，很明显，你可以看到他们在1660年是怎么做的。君主制已经恢复了。
Charles II is back. You know, this is his grandfather. His grandfather's escaped. They have a huge bonfire and fireworks. And Peeps records it in his diary. And then in 1664, do you know what he does on Bonfire Night, Tom? He goes to see Macbeth. Of course.
查尔斯二世回来了。你知道的，这是他的祖父。他的祖父逃脱了。他们举办了一场盛大的篝火晚会和烟花汇演。佩皮斯把这件事记录在他的日记里。然后在1664年，你知道他在篝火之夜做了什么吗，汤姆？他去看《麦克白》了。当然。
Yes. Perfect. Yeah. He goes to see Macbeth. Of course. Yes. Perfect. Yeah. He goes to see Macbeth. On the way home, their coach has to be diverted because there are so many bonfires. I mean, it all adds up. But then November the 5th, 1666, doesn't he say, I've seen no bonfires? Because obviously, having huge bonfires a few months after the Great Fire of London. It would not be sensitive timing at all.
是的。完美。是的。他去看《麦克白》了。当然。是的。完美。是的。他去看《麦克白》了。在回家的路上，他们的马车不得不绕道，因为有太多的篝火。我的意思是，这一切都合情合理。但随后在1666年11月5日，他难道没有说，我没有看到篝火吗？因为很显然，在伦敦大火几个月后燃起巨大的篝火，这绝对不是一个敏感的时机。
It would be poor form. It would be very poor form. The other thing that kind of swells the mood of Protestant celebration that you're celebrating on the 5th of November is that 1688, the Glorious Revolution, when the Catholic James II is forced to flee following the invasion of the Dutch Prince of Orange. This is your moment now to talk about the Dutch. Yes.
这会很不合时宜。这会是非常不合时宜的举动。另一种增强11月5日庆祝情绪的新教狂热的因素是1688年的光荣革命，当时天主教徒詹姆斯二世在荷兰奥兰治亲王入侵后被迫逃亡。现在轮到你谈论荷兰人了。是的。
For the duration of this podcast series. This is the allotted time to talk about the Dutch. The Stadtholder, descendant of William the Silent, who'd been assassinated, leader of a Protestant war against the the catholic absolutism of um louis the 14th and he lands at torbay on the 5th of november and his birthday is the 4th of november yeah bishop gilbert burnett a year later on the 5th of november he preaches to the House of Lords and he says, all this proves, and this is a direct quote, we are God's favourite people. Because God has chosen this day and he just gives us everything. It's the day that keeps on giving.
在这个播客系列持续期间。这是专门用来谈论荷兰人的时间。执政官，曾被刺杀的沉默者威廉的后代，反对路易十四的天主教专制主义的新教战争的领袖，他在11月5日登陆托贝，而他的生日是11月4日。是的，吉尔伯特·伯内特（Gilbert Burnet）主教一年后在11月5日向英国上议院发表布道，他说，这一切都证明了——这是一句原话——我们是上帝最宠爱的人。因为上帝选择了这一天，而且他给了我们一切。这是一个不断给予的节日。
The defeat of plots, the arrival of Dutchmen, you know, what's not to like? So it's very much the idea of England as a chosen nation and a Protestant nation. And it kind of cements in anti-popery as the kind of the great vibrant English kind of British tradition. Because obviously, William III goes on to invade Ireland to defeat Catholic armies there. And so the legacy of that endures to this day in Northern Ireland. But in England, it does start to become complicated because certainly by the beginning of the 19th century, the idea that Catholics are the inveterate enemies of Protestant England has been complicated by the fact that lots of Catholics have been executed in Paris
阴谋的挫败，荷兰人的到来，你知道的，有什么理由不喜欢呢？所以这非常符合英格兰作为天选之国和新教国家的观念。它将反天主教情绪巩固为伟大而充满活力的英格兰（即英国）传统。因为显而易见，威廉三世随后入侵爱尔兰以击败那里的天主教军队。因此，这一遗产在北爱尔兰延续至今。但在英格兰，事情开始变得复杂起来，因为到19世纪初，天主教徒是信奉新教的英格兰的死敌这一观念，已经被许多天主教徒在法国大革命期间在巴黎被处决这一事实所复杂化。信奉新教的英格兰人开始意识到，可能存在比天主教徒更可怕的敌人。所以这就是我认为盖伊·福克斯登场的时刻。是的。
under the French Revolution. And Protestant Englishmen have kind of woken up to the realisation that there might be kind of foes worse than Catholics. So this is the point at which I think Guy Fawkes comes in. Yes. So you can see there are lots of plays about Guy Fawkes in the early 19th century. And there's this sort of growing sense of Guy Fawkes becoming a bit of an anti-hero, you know, a swashbuckling romantic. Well, he's kind of a hero of pantomimes and things, isn't he? Yes, there's lots of comedies about him, bizarrely.
所以你可以看到，在19世纪初有很多关于盖伊·福克斯的戏剧。并且有一种不断增长的趋势，即盖伊·福克斯开始变成某种反英雄，你知道的，一个耀武扬威的浪漫主义人物。嗯，他有点像滑稽剧之类的主角，对吧？是的，有很多关于他的喜剧，离奇的是。
And it's nothing about the Protestant-Catholic divide. There's a revival of that in the 1850s when the um catholic hierarchy is reintroduced into but what about when when so 1829 the catholic emancipation i don't think that did make a big massive well maybe it did and i just haven't picked up on it one thing we haven't mentioned of course is the export of this so what's really fascinating is that throughout the 18th century people are celebrating it with such gusto in America. So there's all sorts of, they call it Pope Day in New York, and they burn effigies of the Pope, the devil, and Bonnie Prince Charlie.
这与新教和天主教的分裂毫无关系。在1850年代，当……天主教等级制度重新引入时，这种分裂曾一度复苏。但是，当……所以1829年的天主教解放运动，我不认为那造成了非常巨大的影响……好吧，也许它确实造成了，而我只是没有注意到。我们当然还没有提到的一点是这个节日的向外传播。所以真正迷人的是，在整个18世纪，人们在美洲以极大的热情庆祝它。所以有各种各样的庆祝活动，他们在纽约称之为“教皇日”（Pope Day），他们焚烧教皇、魔鬼和英王长孙查尔斯的肖像。
That's a good range. It's a good, but it's a range that makes sense, right? They're all on the same team. They're on Team Antichrist. Yes. And in Boston, the rival North and South Ends, kind of working class districts, they both produce popes. And there's a big thing in Boston on Bonfire Night where you try and grab the other person's,
这是一个不错的组合。这是一个很好的，但也是一个合乎逻辑的组合，对吧？他们都在同一阵线。他们属于反基督战队。是的。在波士顿，互为竞争对手的南北区（也就是工人阶级社区）都会制造教皇肖像。在波士顿的篝火之夜有一个盛大的活动，你得试着去抢夺对方的、
the other district's pope and burn that as well as your own. Great fun. So it becomes a massive punch up to try and get the other side's pope and then burn it. That's better than the Super Bowl, isn't it? The fact that Boston has turned its back on that tradition I find very sad. I know they've had a lot of Irish and Italian immigration
另一个区的教皇肖像，然后连同你自己的肖像一起烧掉。太有趣了。所以这变成了一场为了抢夺对方教皇并将其烧毁而进行的巨大群殴。这比超级碗还要精彩，不是吗？波士顿竟然背叛了这一传统，我对此感到非常悲伤。我知道他们经历了很多爱尔兰和意大利移民，
and there's a lot of Catholics now, but come on they can put their confessional stuff to one side. I suppose also they've had a revolution that's got rid of the British. Yes, so you know what George Washington said about Bonfire Night? No, what did George Washington say? A ridiculous and childish custom. I mean, that just confirms my view that George Washington
现在有很多天主教徒，但拜托，他们可以把告解圣事那一套先放一边。我想他们也经历过一场摆脱英国统治的革命。是的，所以你知道乔治·华盛顿对篝火之夜是怎么说的吗？不知道，乔治·华盛顿说了什么？这是一个荒谬而幼稚的风俗。我的意思是，这正好证实了我的观点，即乔治·华盛顿
is one of the most boring men who ever lived. Very dull man. Well, we cancelled him, didn't we? Yeah, we did. His statue deserves to come down for his attitude to Bonfire Night alone. And I see that they've cancelled Thomas Jefferson as well. Yeah, probably another Bonfire Night sceptic. We were ahead of the curve there.
是有史以来最无聊的男人之一。非常乏味的男人。好吧，我们取消他了，对吧？是的，我们确实取消了他。仅凭他对篝火之夜的态度，他的雕像就该被推倒。我看到托马斯·杰斐逊也被取消了。是的，大概是另一个对篝火之夜持怀疑态度的人。我们在那方面走在了潮流的前面。
Right, anyway, so we are alienating all our american listeners well i'll tell you who we should please therefore we need to win listeners in guildford to make up for it because uh guildford was the head was was a real bonfire night place in the mid-19th century so throughout the 1850s and 60s yeah it's a commuter town, basically, now. It would be taken over by people called the Guildford Guys, who were a mob. And it was a no-go area for the police. The Guildford Guys were rampaged.
好啦，不管怎样，所以我们正在疏远我们所有的美国听众。好吧，我来告诉你我们应该取悦谁，因此我们需要在吉尔福德（Guildford）赢得听众来弥补这一点，因为吉尔福德曾是一个真正的篝火之夜圣地，尤其是在19世纪中期。所以在整个1850年代和60年代，是的，它基本上现在是一个通勤城镇。它会被一群被称为“吉尔福德家伙们”（Guildford Guys）的暴徒占领。这里成了警察的禁区。“吉尔福德家伙们”横行霸道。
I can't imagine Guildford as a no-go area for the police. A no-go area because the mob would take it over upon finding it, smashing stuff up and fighting. And in 1863, they had to send in infantry and dragoons to deal with the people of Guildford because they were so overexcited about Bonfire Knight. Well, the character of Surrey Towns really changed, didn't they? Yeah.
我无法想象吉尔福德会成为警察的禁区。之所以是禁区，是因为暴徒一旦发现警察就会接管这里，到处打砸抢烧并引发冲突。在1863年，他们甚至不得不派遣步兵和龙骑兵去对付吉尔福德的居民，因为他们对篝火之夜实在是太兴奋了。萨里郡城镇的性格真的变了，对吧？是的。
So, obviously, Guy Fawkes, I think, ends up looming larger and larger. So, Penny for the Guy. Small boys. They make kind of figures kind of human figures which they call the guy and they put him in go-karts didn't they i put around i did yeah i did yeah so did i i i'd loved the penny for the guy i'm very sorry that it and this is where american listeners can can can feel pleased because basically there was a tradition where small boys would push this guy around in
所以，很明显，盖伊·福克斯，我认为，最终显得越来越重要。所以，“给盖伊一个便士”（Penny for the Guy）。小男孩们。他们制作那种人形的玩偶，他们称之为“盖伊”，然后把他们放在手推车里，对吧？我以前也这样做过。你做过？是的，我做过。我也是。我以前很喜欢“给盖伊一个便士”，我非常遗憾它……这就是美国听众可以感到高兴的地方，因为基本上有一个传统，小男孩们会用手推车推着这个“盖伊”到处走，
a go-kart and essentially extort money so yeah a penny for the guy but that tradition now has been taken over by the american custom of halloween yeah so the guys i mean nobody i haven't seen a guy for no no no um also the other tradition i remember from so this is 1970s is the tradition was that fireworks have become quite domestic you know you bought fireworks you did them in your back garden the tradition was that of the 20 fireworks 10 didn't go off yeah and the other 10 basically went off in your father's face yeah and it was just it was basically you know it was it was kind of party season at a and e because it was just full of middle-aged men lost an eye because a firework had gone off in their face or something.
本质上就是敲诈勒索钱财，所以……“给盖伊一个便士”。但这一传统现在已经被美国的万圣节习俗所取代了。所以这些“盖伊”——我的意思是，没有人……我已经很久没见过“盖伊”了。没有，没有。此外，我还记得19世纪70年代的另一个传统是，烟花变得相当家庭化，你知道的，你买了烟花，在后院燃放。传统的规律是，在20个烟花中有10个不会响，
So I suppose the decline of that might be down to health and safety. I think, yeah. I'm sure it must also be down to sensitivities over anti-Catholic celebrations. Do you think that's really true? I think a bit. Even among the drippiest, most pious. No, I think it is a bit. And I think that, I think it's also been complicated
而另外10个基本上是在你父亲的脸上炸开的。这基本上就是急诊室的派对季，因为它到处都是因为烟花在脸上炸开而瞎了一只眼的中年男子。所以我猜，这项活动的衰落可能归咎于健康和安全原因。我想，是的。我确信这也一定归咎于对反天主教庆祝活动的敏感心理。你觉得这真的是真的吗？我觉得有点这方面的原因。即使在那些最温吞、最虔诚的人当中也是如此。不，我认为确实有一点。而且我认为，这也因为……
by nervousness about, isn't this terrorism? A bit. Really? Do you think so? I do. I do think that. I think the idea of celebrating
对这种事情是否属于恐怖主义的焦虑而变得更加复杂。有一点。真的吗？你这么觉得吗？我确实这么觉得。我认为这种庆祝
what is essentially a kind of sectarian festival has become, dare I say, problematic. I'm going to two Bonfire Nights. Of course you are. Of course you are, because you're the robust voice festival has become, dare I say, problematic. I'm going to two Bonfire Nights. Of course you are. Of course you are, because you're the robust voice of Middle England. I'm going to warn you.
本质上属于宗派主义节日的行为，已经变得——我敢说——充满争议。我要去参加两个篝火之夜。你当然会去。你当然会去，因为你是中产阶级英格兰的坚强声音。节日已经变得——我敢说——充满争议。我要去参加两个篝火之夜。你当然会去。你当然会去，因为你是中产阶级英格兰的坚强声音。我要警告你。
The first one is, it's at Soho Farmhouse. You can't get much more robust Middle England. Where Harry met Meghan. I'm sure Meghan doesn't approve of it. Oh, she'd be. I mean, so how is she? They could well end up on the lewis bonfire because in lewis which is this place it's in sussex isn't it lewis yeah um so they get gideon mantel who we talked about in the dinosaur episode right they get 80 000 people lining the
第一个是，在苏荷农庄（Soho Farmhouse）。再也没有比这更具中产阶级英格兰特色的地方了。哈里遇到梅根的地方。我确信梅根不会赞成这个。噢，她会的。我的意思是，她会怎么想呢？他们很可能会出现在刘易斯（Lewes）的篝火晚会上，因为在刘易斯这个地方，它在苏塞克斯，对吧？刘易斯，是的，呃……所以他们有吉迪恩·曼特尔（Gideon Mantell），我们在恐龙那一集里谈到过他，对吧？他们有8万人涌上
streets because they have these colossal effigies they've had margaret thatcher they've had george bush they've had osama bin laden they've had jerry halliwell they've had all the big names they've had margaret thatcher they've had george bush they've had osama bin laden they've had jerry halliwell they've had all the big names they've had david cameron wayne rooney donald trump they had six donald trump's one year um and they always pick people who've been in the news and set them on fire and then it's always sort of a little bit of outrage in the newspapers afterwards how could you possibly burn wayne rooney or whoever um so i i wouldn't be surprised to see harry and and Meghan on that. I'm not saying I agree with it, for those listeners who are big Meghanophiles. But do you not think that's plausible, Tom?
街头，因为他们有这些巨大的肖像。他们做过玛格丽特·撒切尔、乔治·布什、本·拉登、杰瑞·哈利韦尔（Geri Halliwell），他们有过所有的大人物。他们做过玛格丽特·撒切尔、乔治·布什、本·拉登、杰瑞·哈利韦尔，他们有过所有的大人物。他们做过大卫·卡梅伦、韦恩·鲁尼、唐纳德·特朗普，有一年他们做了六个唐纳德·特朗普的肖像……他们总是挑选那些上过新闻的人然后把他们烧掉。接着报纸上总会有那么一点愤怒的抗议声音：“你怎么能烧韦恩·鲁尼或者不管是谁呢？”所以我对看到哈里和梅根出现在上面一点也不感到惊讶。我并不是说我赞同这一点，对于那些梅根的超级粉丝听众来说。但是汤姆，难道你不觉得这很合理吗？
I think it's plausible, yeah. Who would you like to burn? Who would you burn if you had to do a... Oh, that's a good question. Do you know, it's going to sound very witty. I'm not really the burning type. I know you're not. I knew you wouldn't answer the question.
我觉得这很合理，是的。你想烧谁？如果你必须做一个……噢，这是个好问题。你知道的，这听起来会非常机智。我其实不是那种喜欢烧东西的人。我知道你不是。我就知道你不会回答这个问题。
Who would you like to burn? Oh, God, so many people. Who's head of your long list? Oh, I don't know. To be honest, I find it very hard to narrow it down. Okay. I'd probably burn some of our rival history podcasters. How about that? That's a good one. Yes, I like that okay so we've we've ducked that for our very
你最想烧谁？哦，天哪，有那么多人。你的长名单上排在第一位的是谁？哦，我不知道。说实话，我发现很难缩小范围。好吧。我可能会烧掉我们的一些历史播客竞争对手。你觉得怎么样？那是个好主意。是的，我喜欢这个。好吧，所以我们出于非常
different reasons um but one a bit one way in which guy fawkes has kind of endured so we mentioned earlier about um beef vendetta yes uh which is um alan moore's comic. Very good comic. So in the 80s. Although, I mean, you can't... Because it revolves around the whole premise. It's an alternative history of the 80s, isn't it? Yeah. In which the premise is that Michael Foot wins the general election in 1983.
不同的原因避开了这个问题。但是，盖伊·福克斯以某种方式得以延续的一个方面是——我们之前提到过《V字仇杀队》（V for Vendetta），是的，那是阿兰·摩尔（Alan Moore）的漫画。非常棒的漫画。所以在80年代。虽然，我的意思是，你不能……因为它围绕着整个前提。这是80年代的平行历史，对吧？是的。其中的前提是迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot）赢得了1983年的大选。
Yeah, very implausible. That was never going to happen. No. So Michael Foot wins the election in 1983. I'm so glad we've got Michael Foot into this podcast. He unilaterally disarms Britain. There's then a nuclear war. Britain escapes the nuclear war because of Michael Foot.
是的，非常不可信。那绝对是不可能发生的。不。所以迈克尔·富特赢得了1983年的大选。我很高兴我们把迈克尔·富特扯进了这个播客里。他单方面解除英国的武装。随后发生了一场核战争。英国由于迈克尔·富特而逃过了核战争。
But then there's a fascist takeover. Yeah. And there's a kind of evil dictator. And there's a shadowy figure who's basically Guy Fawkes who ends up blowing up Parliament. That's right. There's a very poor film of this, but I think it's a really brilliant graphic novel.
但随后发生了一场法西斯政变。是的。然后出现了一个某种邪恶的独裁者。还有一个神秘人物，基本上就是盖伊·福克斯，他最后炸毁了议会。没错。关于这个有一部很烂的电影，但我认为这是一部真正出色的图像小说。
A great window into the sort of paranoia of the 80s. It's very Wiltshire-phobic. Is it? Yes. Is that where there's a concentration camp in Wiltshire? Yes, at Lark Hill, which is just above Stonehenge. Oh, Tom. And you whinge about a tunnel and it's a concentration camp.
这是了解80年代那种偏执情绪的一个极好的窗口。这里对威尔特郡极其充满偏见。是吗？是的。那里的威尔特郡有一个集中营吗？是的，在拉尔克希尔（Lark Hill），就在巨石阵上方。哦，汤姆。你为了一个隧道抱怨个不停，而那竟然是个集中营。
No, that wasn't a concentration camp. He's made it up. He's made it up. He's made it up. So I boycott it. I think it's unacceptable bigotry against Wiltshire. Okay, well. I think he... I didn't think that was the bigotry.
不，那不是集中营。那是他瞎编的。那是他瞎编的。那是他瞎编的。所以我抵制它。我认为这是对威尔特郡不可接受的偏见。好吧，那么。我认为他……我不认为那是偏见。
I think he chose Lark Hill because he'd been on a walking holiday at Salisbury Plain and somebody was rude to him and refused him a drink of water in Lark Hill. So he's immortalised it. Wow. Oh, and also in that, there's a kind of portent, which is also unsourceably plain, kind of portent down biological weapons centre, which leaks a kind of a plague.
我认为他选择拉尔克希尔是因为他曾在索尔兹伯里平原（Salisbury Plain）徒步度假，有人对很不礼貌，拒绝在拉尔克希尔给他一杯水。所以他把这件事永载史册了。哇。哦，而且在那部作品中，有一个某种不祥的预兆，那也是一个无法追溯出处的平原，某种位于生物武器中心的不祥预兆，那里泄漏了一种瘟疫。
God, he's really got it in for Wiltshire. He really has. Yeah, he really has. But there's a kind of COVID-y type scenario of a virus escaping from a government lab. But that kind of established, as I said, the idea that these masks, Guy Fawkes masks, and I think Anonymous used it, who are kind of a radical group online. That's right. The Occupy movement, we're very keen on it.
天哪，他是真的很讨厌威尔特郡。他真的是。是的，他真的是。但那里有一种类似新冠疫情的病毒从政府实验室泄漏的场景。但这建立起了一种——正如我所说——这种面具的观念，盖伊·福克斯面具，我认为匿名者组织（Anonymous）使用过它，这是一个线上的激进组织。没错。占领运动非常喜欢它。
So those are on the left. And then on the right, you've got the Guido Fawkes website, which is a kind of conservative anarchist. That's a very good point. Yeah, so Guy Fawkes has become a sort of generic anti-establishment icon. So on the Guido Fawkes website, I think the tagline is the only honest man to enter Parliament. Yeah. The only man to enter parliament in with honest intention which is which is an old joke which has been kind of recycled
所以那些是左翼的。然后在右翼，你有“圭多·福克斯”（Guido Fawkes）网站，这是一个保守的无政府主义网站。这真是个好点子。是的，所以盖伊·福克斯已经变成了一个泛泛的反建制偶像。所以在“圭多·福克斯”网站上，我记得标语是“进入议会的唯一诚实的人”。是的。“怀着诚实意图进入议会的唯一一人”，这是一个被循环使用的老笑话，
because the whole premise of the website is that it's gossip that's designed to of course the gun powder the gunpowder plotters were not libertarians anarchists no you know proto-socialists or any of these things no they uh a world world Robert Catesby's ideal world would presumably have been rather like 17th century France or something a more absolute monarchy with him in a leading position it's all about social advancement
因为该网站的整个前提是它是旨在……当然，火药阴谋的策划者并不是自由意志主义者、无政府主义者，也不是什么准社会主义者之类的人。不，他们……罗伯特·卡茨比（Robert Catesby）理想中的世界大概会非常像17世纪的法国之类的国家，一个由他担任领导地位的更加专制的君主国。这一切都是为了社会晋升。
yes well as you say it's Bullingdon Club boys they haven't got the jobs they wanted yes exactly so is that it yeah i think we've put the we have we have the the last embers are dying out i'm trying to think of a bonfire related it's not really it's not really working the hedgehogs have been taken to safety i think that's the notion which we should end we should anyone who's building a
是的，正如你所说，这是布灵顿俱乐部的那群小子，他们没有得到他们想要的职位，完全没错，就是这样。是的，我想我们已经把……最后一星火星正在熄灭，我正试图想一个与篝火有关的比喻，但这不太对，不太管用。刺猬已经被转移到安全的地方了，我想这就是我们应该结束的概念，我们应该提醒任何在建
bonfire remember to check it for hedgehogs yeah you should build a bonfire by the way yeah and absolutely you should commemorate bonfire night because it's old-fashioned and it's patriotic. Yeah, but also, as Ronald Hutton in our previous episode said, it's also very ancient. The tradition of lighting bonfires is actually much older than, around this time, it's much older. But look out for the hedgehogs and you'll make Tom Holland happy. Yeah, you will.
篝火的人，记得检查里面有没有刺猬。顺便说一句，是的，你应该建一座篝火，而且绝对应该纪念篝火之夜，因为它既老派又爱国。是的，不过正如罗纳德·赫顿在我们上一期节目中所说，它也非常古老。点篝火的传统实际上比现在这个时候要古老得多，要古老得多。但要注意刺猬，这会让汤姆·霍兰高兴的。是的，会的。
Brilliant. All right, well, so this is going out on the 4th of November, so 5th of November is tomorrow. I hope those listening who are going to Bonfire Nights have a wonderful time. Stand back from the fireworks. I hope those of you in foreign climes who don't have the fortune to celebrate this wonderful day don't feel too bad about it. Thanks very much for listening. Bye bye. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
太棒了。好的，这期节目将在11月4日播出，所以11月5日就是明天。我希望收听节目的、准备去过篝火之夜的朋友们能度过一段美好的时光。离烟花远一点。我希望那些身处异国他乡、没有福分庆祝这个美好节日的听众们不要感到太难过。非常感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前听、免广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。